what up guys good morning today i'm
starting off my day with
um
a lot of training i did i'm still
running the get lean program today is
week four day one of it which also
happens to land on fourth of july woke
up you know my regular time 6 6 30 was
at the gym by 7 40 because since i'm in
la right now i have to drive
um
and from
here it's about like a 10 20 minute
drive
um i don't know why i feel so compelled
to give you so many details sorry about
that i think i still have a lot of
pre-workout in my buddy you good dude
wow what did miles do to you
oh then he deserved it okay so taika
wanted to make me breakfast are you okay
i'm gonna hit you in the face
okay one second one second i'm gonna
introduce you
okay
so taika wanted to make me breakfast
um so he's gonna help me today but
because i'm still running macros because
i'm still trying to beat bart
uh for our get lean program competition
uh that
um i need to stay on track even on a
holiday
so i'm gonna make a burrito
i'm gonna use
these tortillas
they taste really bomb macros on these
are okay it's three to three so it's a
one-on-one ratio not really what i look
for i'm gonna use some turkey bacon
with ratios of um
well not ratios but it's 2.5
fat to protein
zero carb which is great i'm gonna use
some egg whites
so this one is zero fat five protein
zero carbs
so
i haven't done the complete math
but um
they're good macros you gotta trust me
on this okay so taika you ready to
you have to cook okay so the first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna chop up
the turkey you ready to chop it up
and then after the turkey
we're gonna um put the turkey and we're
gonna we're gonna cook it a little bit
once we feel like that's cooked then i'm
gonna throw in about
six tablespoons of egg whites okay and
then we're gonna mix it up then that
well that's
while that's cooking then i'm gonna put
this on a flame cook it a little bit
warm it up
you're listening to me dude i'm telling
you the plan
and then we make the burrito okay you
little burrito
okay little burrito i'm a burrito you
are get me i'm a big burrito you're a
big burrito eat it we eat them
but i say more nope i said six are you
ready
okay so the first thing we're going to
do is we're going to measure everything
out so i'm not guessing while the fire
is on okay so i'm going to do the eggs
we're going to do six
tablespoons so hold this and well let's
count all that okay
yeah so don't leave it straight like
that yeah
shake this up
let me open this up
okay ready to rock yeah we're about to
roll baby let's go baby
okay
one
thank you all of it good job
three
three
make sure it's straight like that so it
doesn't spill four
four
four
five
wait let me put it first
count it when it falls in there five
last one
six
don't smell it it never smells good
i didn't smell i smelled it but then i
just know anything okay trust me you
don't want to smell an egg and then you
know what an egg smells like sometimes
protein yeah but you know what else it
smells like sorry you had lint in your
eye i didn't want it to go in your eye
smells like farts
is that funny yeah i like it
do you like the way parts smell
like smelly things oh good i smell that
and then smell it let's smell it no i'm
okay
i believe you look
that's good okay
okay let's cut the turkey little turkey
okay
okay
okay ready
yeah pretend again okay so you have to
be very careful with this knife okay
yeah you have to cut it right behind you
yeah you have to watch where your hands
are you want to stand up
mama could only cut china only to this
part yes but not not too this because
your fingers right yes so i'm going to
show you what to do okay okay so you're
going to turn it do you already have it
your perfect weight no teeth
are you paying attention okay so this
part right here look
this part of the knife is what's going
to cut it and that's really sharp okay
this right here you don't want to cut
and you don't want your fingers to be on
it because you can cut your fingers off
yeah but you're only going to touch that
you could touch this right you see the
difference there's no rigid you see the
ridges there they look like little teeth
yeah you don't want to put your hand
there okay
look mine's a little bit different than
yours which side is the sharp side this
side or this side
don't touch it okay don't touch it don't
touch it
that side yes and you don't want to
touch it because this could cut you
really bad okay this set is okay to
touch but this one do not touch i don't
think
you only have to cut right here yes not
here because your fingers right there
yes don't put that knife on your hands
okay ready so we're gonna hold it
like this and you're gonna cut so you're
gonna cut from here but make sure to
hold this part here okay so it doesn't
move yeah that holds it together so you
wanna cut little pieces like that like
little lines you see what i'm doing
lines i'm gonna make it yeah that's okay
that one's
oh good job that was a perfect one so
you want to do that okay okay
there you go
keep cutting this one yeah that one's
perfect dude
good job
watch your fingers okay always look at
your fingers
there you go monkey
you're a fast learner dude
and i could see you concentrating
good job are you watching for your
fingers
i put i put it here and i put it to the
other one that's good that's good
thinking dude
i keep moving my finger i don't get cut
good job
good job you're doing great
[Applause]
you do yours first don't pay attention
to me yet okay
okay we'll do that we'll do what i'm
doing to yours when you're done hi how's
it going fast
i've been doing it for a long time
that's why
but you're going pretty fast for someone
that it's barely learning you're doing
great
that's okay no you're doing great
good job
not that i'll cut my fingers though
that's great dude
watch those cutie little sausages
wait wait you got it stuck to your knife
right here
be careful ooh this smells pretty good
actually good job
good job
a little bit
yeah well i'm waiting on you it's okay
when you when you cook you want to be
patient okay yeah because moderation
goes
not for kids
it might be a little too big do you
think
look at this size
sorry watch those fingers you don't have
to say sorry
okay
you got it
this part okay
there you go
so monkey can i can i coach you on
something
okay
so this right here you want to use this
part okay i think right now you're
cutting here so it's a little bit hard
so when you cut i think you want to go
or not i think but you want to go like
that
you have to do this wait no don't
measure it ready right there
yep oh i like what you're doing with
your fingers there good job way to go
slow too
nice
perfect
yeah i think that's perfect dude
yeah okay chef's kiss
your chef taika
you still want to be a chef
i'm ratatouille you're ready
yeah watch those fingers good job okay
so now
yep you're going to stack it on top of
each other
so you wanted everything on the same
direction and this tiny one here so now
what you're going to do
you want to stack it leave it like that
do you want to put them all together and
now you're going to cut this way okay
watch your hands okay i'm going to put a
knife here you want to cut this way like
that so you're going to cut like this
make little pieces like that funny
noise
but not the cut people's hair okay
okay
don't don't even play like that move
your hand it makes me nervous
okay
okay so
can i teach you
okay thank you so hold all of it with
your fingers
so you want to hold all of it so what
part are you going to cut first um
[Music]
okay you want to cut this side first
okay so you want to grab it so the whole
thing doesn't move and you're going to
cut like that
so let's cut
okay now one more time but i don't know
do you need to move your fingers a
little bit like this yes that's perfect
okay let's cut it again
i have to move like that that's okay
that's okay
okay watch this thumb so i wouldn't do
it like that
i would do it like this
yeah like that you see how you're kind
of squishing all of it okay so now you
want to watch out for those cuny fingers
okay
chop chop chop chop slap there you go
okay now you can move your fingers a
little bit back
let's push this way here yeah that's
perfect dude
he's doing oh i just touched this part
okay be careful you gotta really pay
attention okay
okay don't even put it close to your
hand okay now what do you do again do
the same thing yeah so you want to
squeeze it wait a minute so squeeze the
yeah squeeze it like that and now watch
where your fingers are you see this
finger is kind of close there you go
good job
no you don't need to do that you could
just keep slicing it there you go
the boat
comes out here
close the pirate boat
and here comes the zombie here comes the
zombie belt
okay watch that finger watch that finger
good job
oh man i think that was your best one
here goes the pirate bows yep
you want to cut that a little bit
that one is kind of big
that's okay he perfect yeah
nice i like a chef that cleans his nose
on his sleeve
very authentic
watch where you're going watch those
fingers those oh that is perfect
perfect look at it ma
watch that finger don't look don't look
away from the knife okay if the knife is
on here you don't want to look at
anything else except for that knife
go look at those fingers
whoa
you almost hit my face
yeah i'll do these
glasses it's okay but you don't want to
put any knife in anyone's face hey
that's really good i don't even think i
don't even think i could tell which
one's tycoos or mama's look which one's
mama's i think whoa i'm so sorry other
than that one is mama's yeah no you did
great it looks the same look at that
good job okay don't do that again don't
do it again it's gross we're gonna cook
it okay wow that was really good
good job monkey
okay let's cook everything
you ready to cook it
you ready to cook it
let's
let's
cook it
okay so now monkey
you spray this a bit
that's probably not the best idea
yes
but they were there no don't do it right
there actually the fire's right there
that's you're still
thank you princess
i mean prince okay ready you you want to
put it yeah okay put together put it
together i like your chicken
do that a little bit okay
start mixing it
okay just hey just watch your hand here
okay because it's really hot yeah mix it
up
good job way to go slow
[Music]
i think it's perfect that you're going
slow
can i help you a little bit
okay thank you one second
cook that a little bit
are you done cooking
oh look it's getting brown can you see
that can i see yeah
can i can i try sure
[Music]
yeah just pay attention okay watch this
wrist it's getting really close to the
pan
[Music]
so you what you kind of want to do
think about pushing it a little bit so
you're kind of just pushing yeah
push push and then you know what you do
pull it down you pull it back yeah like
that pull it back
for sure just pay attention to this part
so slow push slow push
slow push what about this part what
about this part
good job push push push
pull it back
there you go push push push oh you're
pulling it back still
got it hey there's some stuff to your
to the spatula you know what you want to
do
like that
okay ready
it's time for the egg i'll let you do it
look together together
i think you could do it by yourself so
go from here and then just tilt it
good job can i do it i want to do it
okay one second can you put that on the
side right there
let me lower this a bit i love you there
you go
okay so push slowly and then pull go
push
you can't wait too long with eggs or
else it's gonna burn
yep so
push push push
yeah
you say yuck or yum yum
yum yum
yum it's not young smell it it's almost
delicious over here
because it's all white it'll be yellow
watch it ahead
okay i think we're done
oh my goodness oh my god
gentle gentle
okay it's done can i talk to you yeah
but we gotta talk after okay
look at that
no it's really hot trust me fine
oh because i've done it for a long time
even me who's done it for a long time
still gets burned it's really hot dude
okay
so i'm lucky but
i was lucky you would not love me
okay so taika is really adamant about
serving me
okay chef
can i order a burrito please
go sit down yeah i'm sitting right here
coming right up and a banana
thank you for cooking breakfast for me
dude
oh i don't want to sandwich my love i'm
going to eat this and then i'll let you
know what else i want okay
thank you how about fruit salad
don't eat that yet
yogurt
okay let's get the yogurt
that one right there yeah that one let's
do that
and give me some fruit
uh strawberries blueberries and
raspberries oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
let's go
bye bye
bye bye banana see you later
you go back here brothers you go back to
your brothers i like that
and your sisters
yeah yeah yeah right there
oh i like that little bit jiggle
okay that was okay fine
oh careful careful
maybe you could do one at a time
oh my god here you got to get the
blueberries
i practiced a lot of this you practice a
lot of it oh i see yeah
thank you so much chef i'm ready to eat
can i eat now no i have to put it
in this in a plate oh it's okay can i
eat it like that please no
okay
i don't know if i'm ever gonna get to
eat but
that's that's the goal today i'm trying
to eat my breakfast yes i'll give you a
bowl okay let's go
okay so you want to do this
okay
yeah that's pretty good
yeah this is pretty good
yes that's pretty good okay okay i think
that's enough oh don't wipe it on your
shirt
that's enough
yeah raspberries are awesome thanks chef
for licking your fingers okay what's the
next one a strawberry my favorite yeah
here let me help you
there you go
you have to inspect them first make sure
that they look nice yeah they look nice
uh that's it that's it i don't want any
more nope that's too many oh oh that's
for you
oh man this chef is awesome
okay let me get a handful of blueberries
whoops
let me help you oh man this chef likes
to taste all his stuff oh this one's a
good bad one hold on
no don't lick everything
i like a blueberry
[Applause]
okay i think that's good come on
okay dude don't lick it that's a
horrible chef no no up it can look right
oh okay okay fine can i eat now uh-huh
yay i get to eat
you finish them let me see excuse me
move your hand move your hand
move your hand and move that no out of
the way it's blocking look at those
strawberries that he's talking about no
no i mean
i know but i'm looking at the
i'm looking at the stems
i feel like they're still 90 got it
thank you dude
but i feel like there's a lot here still
this forum says milkshakes
oh my god
so we're just having lunch and i'm
trying to convince taiko why he needs to
eat all his fruits and vegetables and
tell me what you're gonna say um
the baggage come to your mouth and then
yeah we have a real life and then it
goes here and then there and then there
and then there and then there and then
here
and here
[Music]
okay i just kept the
bad guys okay so explain to me where
does the food go and how does it travel
in your body where does it start
yep okay and then where does it go let
me show me
oh yeah yeah yeah and then where
yeah
[Music]
yeah in your intestines
can you say intestines tested
and how many intestines do you have two
yeah
one two yeah and then
what are they called
long intestine and pesticides no
short intestine
good job okay so all the good all the
good nutrients where do they go
give me some examples of where the good
stuff goes
yeah and where else
your
yeah and your teeth
yeah your muscles your eye your hair
your brain
good hearing yeah yeah yeah
yeah good bones
yeah what about the bad stuff where does
the bad stuff go and the toilet
what is it called
wait
good job
good job
oh yeah yeah way too much i didn't get
it
okay ways to come up come back so you
can finish eating your
mama
baby oh no thank you okay let's eat your
lunch come on
he got his cousins to watch the raccoon
party
okay now we're gonna go to the park
let's go